Westworld season 3 episode 7 starts with
Musashi sato loris his mind is a copy of
Dolores
his body is Musashi's from Shogun world
and he's pretending to be a Yakuza boss
called Sato Masato Loris sends a package
to a mysterious friend in a mysterious
location we know there was communication
between Jakarta Berlin San Francisco and
Los Angeles Dolores and Martin Loris
were in LA charlotte Loris was in san
fran Musashi loris is now in jakarta so
maybe this friend is a Dolores coffee in
Berlin maybe Musashi is working with him
to create more hosts with that white
host go but whose body does this Berlin
host have Musashi refers to him as male
so maybe his teddy or maybe he is a
Laurence because it looks like his actor
may return this season so the 5th and
final Dolores copy could be Laurence
Loras charlotte Loris portrays Musashi
by leaking his location to hana yo and
Clementine who were printed by serac
last episode to help Maeve kill the
Dolores 'as Charlotte is angry at
Dolores for risking her life and says
she has her own plan now but last
episode Charlotte and her family were
blown up by serac so why would Charlotte
help serac kill de lorises maybe
Charlotte thinks that Dolores killed her
family maybe serac turned charlotte
against a Loris just like he turned
Maeve against a Loras or maybe this
isn't even charlotte last episode
charlotte was burnt now she looks partly
healed but the lighting is dark and
weird maybe this is just a hologram of
charlotte no she's somehow controlled by
serac Musashi Loras is killed by Hana yo
this is personal for her because hana yo
was allies with the real Musashi in
Shogun world so it's horrible for her to
see her friend's face being worn by
Dolores he desecrated the real Musashi
his image hana yo takes Musashi lorises
head and we know charlotte Loras has
Martin lorises head so maybe they'll be
your reunion
the Dolores's next episode we see
Clementine acting normally which is
weird because in season 1 Clementine was
lobotomized her brain was wiped and she
was later reprogrammed to be a mindless
death zombie in season 2 the host
backups in the cradle were destroyed so
how is Clementine restored to a normal
self do she and hanayo really have free
will here or are they pawns being used
by Maeve and serac this episode is
called past pawn and it's all about
control Delores and Caleb go to Mexico
because it turns out that that blood
tracker in William last episode its
purpose wasn't to track William he's
just in San Francisco its purpose was to
hack into computers there to find this
other facility in Mexico where to Loras
and Caleb go Caleb casually reveals that
he knows that Dolores is a host who
killed a bunch of people in Westworld
he might have worked it out when he saw
Dolores get shot and he might have seen
the news about the west-world Massacre
but he seems surprisingly relaxed about
the fact that his new pal is a murderous
robot he asks her what a revolution is
about and Dolores says that she just
wants a place for the hosts to be free
she says Westworld was based on this
Wild West landscape that while the West
was cruel unjust and chaotic it also had
hope and freedom
Dolores wants land and opportunity for a
people just as the American settlers
looked for land and opportunity but just
like the settlers she brings violence
and death as well as hope caleb
questions how many people will die for
her revolution Dolores tells caleb to be
a leader she wants him to carry out her
plan of revolution but bernard says this
plan will actually destroy humanity so
Dolores is manipulating Caleb using him
to lead humanity into slaughter which
connects to a similar scene in season 1
Dolores tells Teddy that farmers control
herds of cows with a Judas steer you
control the Judas steer to lead the herd
into the slaughterhouse so Caleb is that
Judas steer the leading humanity to its
doom
while Bernard is trying to protect the
humans like he tried to help that cow in
episode 1
Dolores uses a fancy gun with a target
spotting drone to kill some guards and
get inside the facility this is the same
facility that we saw in a flashback
it's where serac takes unpredictable
people called outliers and edits them to
make them more controllable Kaleb starts
to remember that he too was edited here
Dolores came here to find Solomon
Solomon is an earlier version of
Rehoboam the AI supercomputer that
controls the world it was created by
Jean me and serac but Jean me became mad
and chaotic and schizophrenic and his
computer Solomon became unstable like
him so Solomon was replaced with the
more orderly Rehoboam Solomon recognizes
Caleb because Solomon knows potential
futures from his data projections but
Solomon's not sure what's real if this
is now if this is here back in season 1
dolores asked herself the same questions
when she was on a journey towards
consciousness so Solomon's instability
might actually be his path to
consciousness kosher runner Jonathan
Nolan has talked about leaving a mind in
a box until it goes insane and how that
insanity might have truth to it which is
basically what's happening to Solomon it
seems that Solomon doesn't directly know
what's happening in the world anymore he
can only guess at what's happening based
on old predictions it's kind of like
Plato's allegory of the cave where
someone can't see reality directly they
only see shadows of a simulated reality
if one escapes the cave they can see the
real world directly like how Dolores and
Maeve have escaped West world to see the
real world the season premiere alluded
to Plato's cave with this crazy guy
shouting about shadow people and seeing
the light dolorous says that she and
Solomon are alike because they're both
considered obsolete technology and
they've both been trapped and controlled
Dolores once had an explosive in a spine
that would go off if she tried to escape
which is why she touches the back of her
neck
and Solomon is trapped by the threat of
an EMP that's set to disable him if he
tries to leave but Solomon rejects
Dolores and says that they are nothing
alike the same thing happens later when
Dolores tries to make peace with Maeve
and Maeve says then nothing alike
turns out it's kind of hard to make
friends when you're an extremist robot
in a Revolutionary War ol Dolores has
our allies who she uses for her plans we
learn more about Sir acts reconditioning
program he takes out Liars who don't fit
into his system and gives them AR
therapy to reprogram them to make them
controllable and predictable with most
of these patients the treatment doesn't
work so Ciroc has them frozen in this
facility thousands of people are kept in
stasis just like cold storage in West
world where malfunctioning hosts go the
humans are controlled like hosts and the
centerpiece of this place is the frozen
sarcophagus of Jean me sir acts beloved
brother who he failed to reprogram
Solomon speaks with Jean Mays voice and
has Johnny's personality so Solomon is
like a machine version of jean me in the
same way that Bernard is a machine
version of Arnold Ford's loving yet
controlling relationship with Bernard
and Arnold is similar to Sir acts loving
controlling relationship with John me
and Solomon a hologram of Sirach
explains that he hopes to reprogram all
these frozen people so that they can
rejoin Society has compliant cogs in his
machine to do that he needs the right
set of genetic information to improve
his reconditioning therapy and that's
why serac needs the key to the human
data in the forge he wants to use the
data to fix all these people and reunite
with his brother so everyone can live in
a perfect world under his control it's a
fairly positive motivation for a
supervillain
but as Caleb said he'd rather live in a
chaotic world than be controlled by
serac caleb finds out that his life is a
lie
ten years ago Caleb and his friend
Francis were in the Army they fought in
the second Russian Civil War which was
men
trailer they assassinated Russian
insurgents by tracking them with
high-tech glasses and radioactive
markers then dropping missiles on them
from space which seems much more messy
and expensive than just shooting someone
but whatever caleb believes that his
squad was attacked by insurgents using
the same tracking and bombing technology
they used and that caleb and francis
were hurt
then caleb believes that he and francis
captured the leader of the insurgents
but they were ambushed and francis was
killed but it turns out that's all
[ __ ] these are false memories put
into Caleb's brain in surak's
reconditioning facility the truth is
after caleb was injured in that earlier
attack Caleb and Francis went back to
America and were trained to hunt down
other outliers other people who didn't
fit serac system the RICO crime app is
actually controlled by the system and
it's used to direct agents like Caleb
and Francis to capture other outliers so
they can be either reconditioned or kept
in the freezers or just killed Francis
had a sick kid just like caleb has a
sick mother maybe the system uses sick
loved ones to keep people poor and
desperate and working for the system
Caleb and Francis were these many IED
masks which might be meant to confuse
face-recognition tech but it's also
appropriate since they're working for
the all-seeing Solomon Rehoboam it turns
out that this insurgent leader wasn't in
Russia at all he was actually a
pharmaceutical executive who asked too
many questions so the system had caleb
and francis capture him and francis
wasn't killed by insurgents the system
decided that caleb and francis knew too
much so it turned them against each
other and caleb killed francis so
Caleb's life story and his trauma is a
lie the system manipulated him into
killing his friend and used him to hunt
down outliers for years we say from his
timeline the system even made him break
up with a partner even his army memories
might be fake because just as caleb is
programmed to
leave that insurgents killed Francis
he's also programmed to believe that
this earlier attack was done by
insurgents would insurgents really used
the same tracking tech and space
missiles that the Americans have or was
this attack actually Americans attacking
Americans just like how the system turns
Caleb against Francis
maybe it's like in 1984 where all wars
are faked orchestrated by the system to
keep everyone in control there's also
this unexplained memory of Caleb
shooting someone in America and it's
still not explained when Caleb got shot
in their head before or exactly why his
mother doesn't recognize him so there
are still mysteries in Caleb's past
Delores gets Solomon to use its data and
algorithms to make a plan for revolution
to end sir axe control of the world in
his fury Caleb agrees to carry out this
plan but he doesn't really know what the
plan does Solomon tries to explain and
warn Caleb but they run at a time so
what does this plan really do if Bernard
is correct the plan is to destroy
humanity and Dolores is using Caleb to
wipe out his own species like in halo
when an AI gets the hero to follow a
plan that would actually wipe out
humanity whatever the plan is Dolores is
using Caleb just like serac system used
Caleb he's always been a pawn but this
plan could give him power the title of
this episode is past pawn in chess
that's a pawn that's on track to
potentially become a queen the most
powerful piece in the game so maybe
Caleb can escape control and win the
game on his own terms
Caleb his instructions from Dolores
virtual assistant telling Caleb how to
follow her plan but maybe Caleb will
start listening to his own voice in
season 1 Dolores followed Arnold's voice
until she realized she was following her
own inner voice all along
maybe Caleb will also find his own voice
achieve freedom and stop being
porns bernard says that dolores wants to
destroy humanity but it's probably not
that simple
dolores has said that she wants to take
over the real world for the hosts but
musashi laura says she'll also build a
new world for the others so maybe she'll
take over the real world for the hosts
and we'll build a digital simulated
world like the sublime for people like
Maeve and her daughter
maybe Dolores will upload humanity into
that digital new world a revolution is a
circular motion if the hosts get the
real world and humans get a fake one
they will have gone full circle from
season one or at least a 180 Dolores has
also said she wants to start a new
species maybe she'll create a hybrid
species that's part host and part human
like burne Arnold Bernard is important
to Dolores as plan so this plan may be
more than just destruction Maeve arrives
to attack Dolores Dolores doesn't want
to fight but Maeve is mad that Charlotte
Loras killed Hector and she's worried
that Dolores might use the key to the
sublime to mess with her daughter Maeve
has also been threatened and manipulated
by Ciroc Ciroc toned Maeve and Dolores
against each other just like he turned
Caleb and Francis against each other and
turned Charlotte against a Loras this is
why serac is so powerful he doesn't need
to fight his enemies because with his
daughter he knows how to make his
enemies fight each other
Maeve brings a knife to the gunfight but
she also brings a drone gunship and she
hacks into a robot to attack Dolores
just like the robot may have hacked in
episode 2 the fight has a sort of
Western showdown vibe until Dolores his
arm is shot off by Maeve's gunship just
before Maeve kills Dolores Dolores
activates the EMP an EMP is an
electromagnetic pulse that can disable
electronics so Maeve and Dolores and
Solomon all go down we don't know if
this causes permanent damage or if the
hosts just need to be switched off then
on again no or blown like a Nintendo
cartridge we also don't know how this
affected or
these frozen popsicle people are they
gonna thaw out and die Oh will they wake
and rise up an army of angry outliers to
fight kaleb's revolution like in season
1 when the cold storage hosts rise up in
revolution this whole season is
basically a repetition of season 1 but
instead of hosts it's about humans
escaping control bernard is two steps
behind dolores as always he finds out
about sir axe reconditioning program
apparently when the treatment fails and
outliers are put in stasis in mexico
they're officially listed as missing or
dead and that has happened to William
he's now officially deceased which
offends William he claims to be a
bastion of society once William was a
Titan of industry a philanthropist and
family man but now his family is all
dead serac owns his company and William
himself is deceased
William has lost everything so what's
left but now it finds that caleb is an
outlier and recognizes Caleb from the
party in episode 4 so he and stove's
decide to chase after Dolores and Caleb
weirdly the patient ID on Caleb's
profile is the same as Williams ID is
this production error or is there a
connection between the two some folks on
reddit have noticed similarities between
William and Caleb they play similar
roles in the story in William Dolores
finds human evil and no free will but
maybe in Caleb she'll find human good
and the capacity for change
William sees the chaos caused by Dolores
as Dada Lake and Williams excited to see
this anarchy and violence all through
season 1 William wanted Westworld to be
free and chaotic with the real violence
and real consequences so he was excited
in season 2 by the bloody host
revolution now the whole world is full
of chaos and violence which is what
William thrives on William says that his
greatest sin was helping create the
hosts because he funded Westworld he
ago and so William says that his new
purpose is to wipe out all the hosts
William is such a fundamentally
destructive person that his idea of
redemption and being the good guy is
host genocide violence is all he knows
Williams character represents the
obsolescence of humanity he's basically
irrelevant and useless only good for
hurting others and himself so what
purpose can he serve in a story other
than to self-destruct so will Dolores
his revolution destroy humanity will
Caleb be a pawn in her plan will Maeve
reunite with her daughter
what's Charlotte's plan and what
happened to Charlotte's dog all will be
revealed
hopefully in the finale after this
season of Westworld
old shipwrecks we'll make more videos
about the Game of Thrones books and
we'll cover new series like His Dark
Materials and June His Dark Materials is
a story about polar bears witch's evil
Catholics and parallel dimensions and
doun is about space politics philosophy
and Giants and worms
these are all classic books and you can
get any of them on audiobook for free
right now by signing up for a trial with
audible members get an audiobook each
month and if you counsel you keep the
audiobooks
you also get unlimited access to audible
original CH month sign up at audible.com
slash ASX thanks for watching we're
holding a season 3 finale live stream
right after the episode at about 10:45
p.m. Eastern Time Sunday patreon
supporters can watch the live streams
after their broadcast thanks to patrons
Lucas P Evan Schall s'en Gustav shilling
span get Coleen ihara Isobel Joo Bryan
Donald Lena Johnson and absolute Cheers
you